endlich scheint es loszugehen nach einem
tödlichen testflug ist virgin galactic
wo kurz davor seine weltraumflüge für
touristen in die tat umzusetzen
das unternehmen hat mehrere erfolgreiche
tests wirklich jetzt vor kurzem
absolviert in wenigen monaten vielleicht
sogar noch in diesem jahr will die firma
von richard branson dann die ersten
touristenflüge ins all anbieten
sensationell wie realistisch ist das
aber jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
ehrlich gesagt hatte ich virgin galactic
fast aus den augen verloren wenn jetzt
nicht jemand auf whatsapp nach dem stand
der dinge gefragt hätte dann gäbe ist
dieses video auch nicht knapp vier jahre
ist der schwere crashs bei einem
testflug her bei dem ein mensch starb
und ein weiterer schwer verletzt wurde
jetzt ist die wie ss unity des
unternehmens virgin galactic wieder
erfolgreich in die luft gestartet
zusammen mit überschallgeschwindigkeit
und zudem auch mit eigenem antrieb bei
den vergangenen tests lügen war es
entweder ohne eigenen antrieb zur erde
zurück blicken oder war die gesamte zeit
am trägerflugzeug befestigt gestartet
wurde dieses mal in der kalifornischen
mojave-wüste 14 kilometer über dem
erdboden wurde das raketenflugzeug vom
trägerflugzeug aus gelingt 30 sekunden
dauert es wohl die motoren gezündet
hatten bis auf macht 1,87 also 1,87
fache schallgeschwindigkeit habe es dann
beschleunigt und so eine höhe von fast
26 kilometern erreicht danach sei die
uss unity zur erde zurück geschwebt und
gelandet dabei war wohl auch der
sogenannte feder modus am flugzeug
eingesetzt worden bei dem die flügel in
einem winkel von 65 grad zum rumpf
gedreht werden
die ihn so stabilisieren dieser extreme
winkel der flügel darf nur im sinkflug
aktiviert werden und weil der co-pilot
diese im oktober 2014 zu früh ausgelöst
hatte war es überhaupt erst zu dem
schlimmen crash bekommt er hat die
federn noch in der schublade freigegeben
die flügel drehten sich in diesen
extremen winkeln und zerrissen die wie
ss enterprise die aktuelle wie ss unity
ist übrigens unter der federführung
eines anderen unternehmens entstanden
als damals die verunglückte wie ss
enterprise jetzt soll es nicht mehr
möglich sein den fehler modus während
der zündung zu aktivieren insgesamt
sollen fünf dieser raketen flugzeuge
entsteht das raketenflugzeug des
britischen unternehmens richard bransons
ist vom typ spaceshiptwo sechs
passagiere und zwei piloten finden in
dem platz der firmenboss demonstriert
damit dass er an die eigene technik noch
ungebrochen glaubt er selbst weder bei
der premiere des ersten
weltraumtouristen fluges tatsächlich mit
dabei sein und ja das an
es soll den angaben des unternehmens
schon in wenigen monaten stattfinden
brands ist persönliches training dafür
ist in vollem gang in einem interview
mit der bbc sagte er dass er sein tennis
training jetzt von zwei auf vier spiele
pro tag ausgewählt habe zudem mache er
ein astronautentraining aber auch alle
anderen interessierten können die sache
jetzt schon dingfest machen der seine
firma verkauft jetzt schon die tickets
250.000 dollar ja ein klacks müssen die
passagiere daraufhin legen um etwa sechs
minuten schwerelosigkeit zu erleben in
einer höhe von etwa 110 kilometern
das gilt das untere grenze des weltraums
dennoch lässt sich sogar die krümmung
der erdkugel aus dieser höhe erkennen
und man kann viele grüße an die flat
erst schicken nach unternehmensangaben
sollen schon rund 600 tickets verkauft
worden seien vom spaceport america im us
bundesstaat new mexico sollen dann die
starts erfolgen wir haben hierbei klicks
und science fiction ja schon öfter
darüber berichtet und übermorgen die
firma von amazon gründer jeff bezos die
liefert sicher mit virgin galactic schon
seit längerem ein spannendes
kopf-an-kopf- rennen darum wer als
erstes touristen in den weltraum
schicken kann anders als virgin galactic
tüfteln die macher von blue origin aber
an einer art raumkapsel die mithilfe vom
fallschirm zurück auf die erde schweben
soll auch sie sollen noch in diesem jahr
zum ersten mal ins weltall fliegen und
zwar bemannt unbekannt ist sie schon
mehrmals geflogen schätzungen zufolge
dürfte der preis für solche ticket nicht
die schwelle von 50.000 dollar
überschreiten so dramatisch viel
billiger ein klacks quasi ja damit sich
die weltraumflüge tatsächlich zum
massentourismus entwickeln können na ja
für 50.000 dollar
doch noch haben die sicherheitsbehörden
dem noch nicht zugestimmt eventuell wird
der durchbruch dazu auch gar nicht in
den usa passieren sondern in saudi
arabien das bereit ist enorm zu
investieren
dem land geht es dabei nicht nur um
touristenflüge ins all sondern auch um
fliegende plattformen für
satellitenstarts es tut also sich so
einiges in dem es tut sich also einiges
in dem bereich hier bei pixar vater
natürlich immer alles über die jüngsten
entwicklung auch weil die community auf
sap also
im weg hält hier mal einen riesen riesen
dank an euch ihr seid hammer wenn ihr
die noch nicht dabei sie mitmachen wollt
dann endet mich bei websense da könnte
er in der redaktion mitmachen und dann
verpasst ja auch kein video über
whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video täglich und
garantiert und zur begrüßung habe ich
ein kleines geschenk für euch einfach
hier draufklicken und am besten auch
mein schwesterkanal klicks um social and
media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür hier
klicken aber nicht die genau die glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken falcon heavy die
revolution der raumfahrt bis dann bleibt
dran